I'm not a soldier.
I fight for my family,
not the crown.
This season,
we spent all this time
like getting it to this point.
We wanted to build the tension
between all the
different characters.
Everyone close to you
always ends up suffering.
Now it’s your turn brother.
Everyone is constantly
changing and evolving.
They manipulate each other so
things become really tense.
There can only ever
be one queen!
And she is me.
Every character has
just hurt each other
so deeply that it’s hard
to trust alliances.
Where we go, he goes.
I still don’t trust him.
Maghra’s trying to
save her people,
her family,
and do the right thing.
Whatever lie you tell,
becomes my lie as well.
If the queen says it,
it’s not a lie.
This season, characters are
extremely complex.
Everyone has some kind of
vendetta against each other.
When you left I was
still the weaker one,
that’s not longer the case.
As the season continues,
we see a tension build
between everyone.
After everything, you still
think you’re special.
We are special.
The cracks that were already
starting to show
throughout season one
just start widening.
The things we do for family.
My own brother stands between us
and victory.
No matter the
outcome, I will lose.
To protect his children.
It's driving force for Baba.
So, when Baba sees his brother,
he wants to just, arrgh!
Full attack!
Everything about Baba
and Edo’s life
was just leading to
this match up.
I don’t want to kill you.
Don’t worry,
you’re not going to.